Speaker 1: All right. I hate that we have
to do this, but once we've opened the door,
we have to do it because people are actually
starting to follow this guy. Bobby Kennedy
Junior held his completely unhinged health policy
roundtable yesterday. I told you, look, look at
this screenshot. I told you about the kooks that
were part of this roundtable, including in the
lower left of the screen, Dr. Sherri Tenpenny.
That's the woman who said everyone you know will
be dead from the vaccine soon and that it's a
form of child abuse. And anyway, she's nuts.
At the bottom center, Dr. Joseph Mercola, who's
been fined for by the FDA for spreading medical
disinformation and some of the products that he
sells. I mean, every single one of these people
I talked to you about yesterday. So Bobby Kennedy
holds this event. These are the last people who
should be dictating or even weighing in on health
policy in the United States. And Bobby Kennedy
comes up with another bonkers claim, now saying
that there is good evidence that vaccine research
is actually responsible for the existence of HIV,
the virus that causes AIDS, RSV, Lyme disease, and
even the Spanish flu. I will tell you, before even
playing the clip that this is not true, but I'm
going to play it for you. We are going to discuss
it. These assertions that Bobby Kennedy makes with
absolutely no hesitation or shame whatsoever
are incorrect and potentially dangerous.
Speaker 2: Let's listen. And you know, we need it.
I will end all gain of function research. I will
I will sign a treaty. And I cannot function
research for, you know, to get all the nations
and get a function research. It's just a disaster.
And it's given us no benefit. It's given us,
you know, everything from Lyme disease to COVID
and many, many other diseases that RSV, which
is now one of the biggest killers of children and
out of, you know, a vaccine lab. You know so well.
And we can go down a whole list of diseases that
you know, down to. And there's good evidence that
even Spanish flu. Aim from AXA vaccine and vaccine
research. And, you know, we don't know and we'll
probably never know. But the you know, they're
very, very strong articles suggesting that.
Speaker 1: Super strong articles. Now it just so
happens everything that he said there is untrue.
This just isn't true. And you have, you know,
these other vectors of medical disinformation
nodding along. And none of those things are
true. I mean, HIV is a virus that attacks the
immune system. It can cause AIDS. It's transmitted
through certain bodily fluids. It was not caused
by vaccine research. It originated from zoonotic
transmission of simian immunodeficiency virus.
Simian, of course, referring to monkeys. That
that's HIV. It's not a result of vaccine research.
RSV is a virus that causes respiratory infections
that can be particularly serious in young kids.
I have friends who have had kids in the hospital,
in ICUs with RSV. It's spread through droplets in
the air or on surfaces. And it is not caused by
vaccine research. It was not created by vaccine
research. Lyme disease. Lyme is a bacterial
infection, not a virus transmitted by ticks.
It can cause rash, fever, fatigue, headaches. It
can be chronic. Extensive scientific studies have
looked at Lyme, and its origins are completely
unrelated to vaccine research. They have to do
with ticks and and mice. And there is so much
research on Lyme. And then Spanish Flu was indeed
a pandemic caused by a strain of H1N1 influenza,
a virus flu infected about a third of the world's
population in the late 19 tens killed up to
50 million people. The exact number there are
different estimates, but up to 50 million is a is
a good estimate and believed to have originated
from birds and spread through human contact.
Now, by the way, the Spanish flu, 1918, not 1917,
the way Trump says there was not a flu vaccine at
the time. The first flu vaccine was developed in
the thirties and introduced in 1938, nearly 20
years after the Spanish flu. So this stuff just
isn't true. And every time we talk about it, some
people will write to me and they'll say, David,
this is so minor. What about Bobby Kennedy's
views on wars or this or that? These beliefs
and the willingness to spread this stuff is
uniquely disqualifying when someone wants to
be president of the United States, that it's it's
not a question of how much does Bobby Kennedy want
to talk about this versus not versus other people
talking about it or forcing him to talk about it
or whatever. These are uniquely disqualifying
views. And by the way, these aren't the only
concerning views that Bobby Kennedy Jr holds.
So health policy panel, even I told you it would
be unhinged. It was even more unhinged than I
expected it to be. And these are simply lies.